Чому Путін насправді напав на Україну?
Це питання задають собі мільйони людей по цілому світу.
Причини, озвучені російським президентом, та його нещодавні публічні виступи -
все це змусило деяких європейських політиків засумніватися у психічному здоров'ї Путіна.
Так, після вторгнення, президент Чехії Мілош Земан, який тривалий час був одним з небагатьох захисників Путіна в Європі,
назвав свого російського колегу "божевільним".
У Єлисейському палаці угледіли "параноїдальні" ознаки у поведінці Путіна.
Джерела в оточенні президента Франції заявляють, що після останньої особистої зустрічі з Путіним Макрон сказав,
що російський правитель став "ізольованішим" і у нього, вочевидь, відбулися "здвиги на тему безпеки".
Один представник німецького бізнесу, який неодноразово протягом останніх двадцяти років зустрічався і спілкувався з російським президентом,
зокрема на закритих зустрічах, вважає, що шукати раціональні причини для пояснення поведінки Путіна нині марно.
Деякі депутати Європарламенту відкрито заявляють, що Путін "втратив відчуття реальності" і "божеволіє".
Чи справді російський президент може бути душевно хворим?
У поведінці Путіна є ознаки, які явно викликають питання, зауважують психотерапевти.
Я є психотерапевтом, як і мої батьки.
Не можу сказати, що Путіну настав час до мене на прийом.
Але, мабуть, у його випадк йдеться не про психічне здоров'я, а про соціально-психологічну проблему, пов'язану з його оточенням.
Той, хто ізолюється від каналів комунікації та зовнішнього впливу, обмежує себе у власній картині світу.
Якщо так дивитися, то так, Путін набув надто аутистичних рис поведінки, він повернутий на самому собі.
Але я не став би говорити, що йдеться про психіатричне захворювання.
Ще три роки тому Дмитро Пєсков стверджував, що Путін не має смартфона,
а для підготовки інформаційних матеріалів для президента використовуються папки з роздруківками.
Судячи з усього, російський лідер не дуже дружить і з інтернетом.
Багато експертів також відзначають, що за два роки пандемії Володимир Путін дуже сильно ізолювався,
явно відчував брак безпосереднього людського спілкування, а також отримання інформації з різних джерел.
Психологи впевнені: коронавірус та ізоляція вплинули на Путіна.
Відомо, що Володимир Путін дуже боїться вірусів та бактерій.
У його офісі у Кремлі стоять системи очищення повітря від вірусів.
Він дуже боїться заразитися.
І якщо в когось легка застуда, йому не можна заходити до одного приміщення з Путіним.
Цей страх у нього давно. Через коронавірус страх захворіти, звісно, посилився.
Ми спостерігаємо ці гротескні сцени, де Путін сидить за семиметровим столом зі своїми генералами
та роздає накази. Він - боязка людина.
Психологи, а також експерти-політологи, не пов'язані з психоаналізом, припускають,
що у Володимира Путіна міг підвищитися рівень агресії і стресу.
Крім того, він може бути одержимий нав'язливими ідеями, і в нього могли розвинутись манії.
Я не можу судити про наявність душевної хвороби у психіатричному сенсі.
Тому що не є лікарем і не можу поспілкуватися з Путіним особисто.
Але фактом є те, що в нього дуже деформоване сприйняття реальності,
певною мірою він має, по суті, патологічну нав'язливу ідею, що Україна є плацдармом Заходу для підкорення Росії,
і що він має вирішити цю проблему.
Що його роль в історії Росії - усунути цю небезпеку та перетворити Україну на державу з обмеженим суверенітетом.
Експерти відзначають також вкрай низький рівень емпатії російського президента.
Водночас зауважують, що не слід забувати і про культурні протиріччя.
Я застеріг би від того, щоб називати Путіна божевільним, говорити, що він душевно хворий.
Так, думаю, що він має патологічні тяжіння, параноїдальні риси, які виявляються у вигляді манії переслідування, відсутності емпатії.
Цього не можна заперечувати. Але я думаю, що у Путіна - свої поняття раціонального,
які не поєднуються з нашими поняттями раціонального у Німеччині та Європі.
І лише тому оголошувати його божевільним - досить небезпечно та спірно.
Професійні психологи зазначають: віддалена постановка діагнозу - дуже складне завдання.
Фактично йдеться лише про припущення та можливі пояснення.
Для того, щоб отримати точний діагноз, пацієнт повинен прийти на прийом особисто.
І зазвичай неодноразово.